I've been called the "supermodel of hands."
I think it's because I've had the longest career of any hand model out there.
In those little seven inches,...
...I have to convey a whole feeling, a whole story, a whole thought process...
...about what's going into that advertising campaign.
I wear gloves quite often, especially when I'm outside,...
...to protect my hands from the elements...
...and from things that can happen, but I take really good care of them,...
...and you'll see why I'm a hand model.
Because I have flawless skin and nice, long nails and very graceful hands,...
...and that's really become my signature.
I never know when I'm gonna have a hand modeling job.
So, I could get called now and have to be somewhere in an hour.
So, my hands always have to be ready to go.